Pittsburgh post-gazette Steelers beat
Ryder feels like it's a weekly
appearance head good morning how are you
I'm great Dan and so far husband what do
we know about Antonio Browns absence
from practice well
they didn't practice Monday they come in
means it's required they come in for
meetings and you know they forty-five
minutes in a locker room they're
supposed to talk to us and you know it's
a short day for them but he blew it off
now it's Tuesdays are off days for the
players lot come in anyway to watch film
and stuff Wednesday they start
practicing and he is in there right now
at the facility was there a reason given
for his absence well as agent through
Rosenhaus said it was a a personal
reason but nobody informed the Steelers
that he would be absent so I think
that's an agent trying to make a better
light of why he missed practice I think
hey nobody knows for sure but I think he
just blew it off because he's been upset
it was obvious on Sunday how upset he
was okay why is he upset I know he had
words with the offensive coordinator
yeah we don't know that because they're
certainly trying to get on the ball it's
they've targeted him 33 times now he's
only caught about half of those and his
average is eight point nine a catch I
believe the average like 15 last year so
and he only has one touchdown catch you
know he he didn't look very happy when
did when Ben it was a pass play but he
scrambled and dove into the end zone for
three our touchdown that brought them
within five of Kansas City with two
minutes left last week everybody was
over there congratulating Ben and
Antonio just looked like he was sulking
coming off the field because he wanted
the ball like I don't know how US wants
the ball Dan always wants the ball even
though you scored a touchdown yes he's
done that before
okay how big of an issue are these
issues locally because you know
nationally we're always curious with the
Steelers because they have the potential
to go to the Super Bowl every year
I'm just curious is is this just sort of
the norm in Pittsburgh or is this a big
deal in Pittsburgh well it it seems to
happen once a year with Antonia last
year he threw a big fit in Baltimore
just what's going crazy tossed over the
Gatorade bucket and that was because he
felt he was open and been through
somewhere else um it happened it seems
to happen once a year anyway but it went
a step further when he put he responded
to the one fellow trade me to see what
happens and then he didn't show up
monday dad that ramped it up a little
bit more Dan and Mike Talman then
yesterday said I am going to speak with
him and it would be happening right now
what's the biggest question you have
from Mike Tomlin right now well I'd like
to know what he's going to do to try and
you know get this under control um it
hasn't worked in the past whatever he's
done you know Antonio has this for lack
of a better word a photographer
following him everywhere and he has
access that nobody else has and he was
sitting on the bench at the game on
Sunday now I heard they they somebody
shoot him away but he has better access
in fact I asked one of our photographers
do you have that kind of access he said
they would tase me for what is this a
videographer is this a reality show you
could see it no he puts it on Instagram
and stuff like that and you know he
follows them everywhere
I yeah I don't know I mean Belichick
banned a guy for Brady last year I think
Mike Tom I might want to start right
there got a lady on bail update for me
you know that that was put on the back
burner yeah it's been forgotten
him TMZ now then he you know he's
partying down there in South Florida
he's jet skiing and you know unless the
photos are out of whack it looks like
he's added a few pounds to yeah I
noticed that that that youngin he's
enjoyed the offseason so far here but
doesn't look like a guy ready to come in
anytime soon yeah no does not if the
Steelers don't make the playoffs dot dot
dot
yes oh you're asking yeah it's gonna
happen yeah they're not gonna make a
move with their head coach I mean you've
been around long enough to remember
Chuck knowing how long he's stuck with
him even though he didn't make the
playoffs seven of eight years now he won
four Super Bowls but you know Bill
Cowher he went through three straight
non-playoff years including two losing
seasons and they responded by giving him
a contract extension he lasted 15 years
this is 12 for Mike
you know maybe they sit down and have
some discussions about some personnel
changes and coaching staff and on the
team but I don't I don't foresee
anything change it two head coaches spot
here's our poll question I'll leave you
with this Edie if you were a player
would you rather play for Bill Belichick
or Mike Tomlin you know I let me just
say this Chad brown was a Steelers draft
choice back in the 90s he left free
agency went to Seattle and he wound up
and do it and then he came back here for
a cup of coffee and I asked him that
question I said what's Bill Belichick
like to play for he said I love it I
love the guy he's he's on point with
everything you know Mike Talman is
probably more fun to play for um but you
know Belichick seems to be more know
like to me in his in Noel's early years
when he didn't take any go probably talk
to you next week
ed thanks for joining us yeah we'll see
what more drama we can come up with yeah
all right Edie Boucher Pittsburgh
post-gazette for more Dan Patrick show
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]